it's been pouring four days in the
lowland rainforests of costa rica's ausa
peninsula a habitat for many rare animal
species biologist Juan Carlos Cruz is
showing us around normally at this time
of the day they're very active a lot of
animals were not using the forest that
after a big crane ditches to stop you
know or during the rain they stopped
doing and moving soon a poison dart frog
flashes its bright warning stripes
nearby we find frogs eggs monkeys like
to eat them so they're probably closed
by 24 Cruz and his team this shows that
investing in conservation pays off in
order to protect land sometimes we have
to buy this area's way also doing
research is very expensive having the
highest technology for monitoring this
animal is also very expensive having
cameras having Raiders having all these
different technology is quite expensive
so we unfortunately need the money to
the conservation Costa Rica has been
planting trees for decades about half
the country's once again covered with
rain forest but that takes financial
resources the International bio Finn
project is bringing finance experts
politicians and investors together to
find ways to fund environmental projects
projects like this Rancher Hugo Camacho
receives a few hundred euros each year
to plant new trees on a party is
pastureland in return he's not allowed
to sell his timber bio Finn coordinator
Guillermo zuniga knows this is a
sacrifice for small farmers like Hugo
Camacho he tells Camacho they're looking
for more funding to protect areas like
this Costa Rica needs private investors
the government says it takes over 470
million euros a year to compensate the
farmers Guillermo zuniga says this is
doable it is not such a big effort and
we have to keep in mind that many why
hope at least that many of that money
much of that money with
Milo of market financial instrument and
where people will realize that it is
important to best for the local wildlife
the rare squirrel monkey for example the
investment pays off their habitat on
Costa Rica's author peninsula as being
preserved
you